welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to black summer has just dropped on
Netflix and this zombie Horror Show has
a hell of a lot to him back from it
his prequel to Z nation has a wealth of
deems to be taken from it and it really
is the perfect introduction to that show
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about black summer's ending and what it
means this is full spoilers ahead so if
you haven't finished the a episode show
and I highly recommend that you turn off
now without the way I hope you enjoy
this video now sit back relax and let's
get into my breakdown of black summer
the show has one hell of an opener that
kicks off the series in spectacular
fashion we follow Rose who after getting
split with her daughter at a military
checkpoint watches her husband transform
into a flesh-eating zombie and sets out
on a mission to make it to a stadium the
promises sanctuary and is where her
child was headed to in the convoy
similar to this are survivors Lance who
watches his girlfriend get killed in
front of him Ryan who could have made
Netflix's the silence infinitely more
interesting he's deaf in case you didn't
know Spears who's a quick talking killer
that's as sharp as his name and
masquerading as a soldier and Barbara
who is like reverse Grand Theft Auto and
is the main reason you should always
wear his seat belt
whilst we don't discover the cause of
what turns the people into the undead it
becomes clear early on that everyone is
infected and similar to the Walking Dead
they reanimate upon death
I guess when there's no more room in
hell at the Dead she'll walk the earth
for those who haven't seen Z nation in
that show we pick up three years after a
zombie virus has swept the world we
follow Murphy who was a prison in May
that is the only survivor of a zombie
bite and the show follows his journey to
New York where a vaccine can be
mass-produced but back to this show
Barbara whose name may be a reference to
Night of the Living Dead states that
she's been on her own for six weeks
which is echoed by other characters so
it appears that this is a widespread
epidemic that is slowly making its way
across the country
there's also a reference to dual by
Steven Spielberg when her
other allies that she's traveling with a
stalked by a mysterious truck a Lord of
the Flies motif makes an appearance too
when some of the characters get trapped
in a school where the pupils have taken
over and as many more Easter eggs that
provide each scenario with a unique
danger for our characters well the
shoulders expertly early on is that it
instantly makes you gravitate towards
these characters and even has a segment
where we see the perspective of a zombie
on the hunt in one of the best one shots
I've ever seen the stories are all
interconnected and there's some amazing
moments where we watch the characters
pass by one another unaware of what they
awaits them whilst the characters are
all heading to the same destination it's
a path that they take that allow for
variation and showcases their true
agendas and mind-state whilst each
character stands strong it becomes clear
early on that this is a show about unity
though there are several obstacles that
cross the protagonists paths and attempt
to separate them
the survivors work better when they
stick together juxtaposing this most of
the humans who separate end up coming to
a gruesome end and this is a piece about
strength in numbers what the show does
brilliantly is that it uses perspective
to show how different moments intertwine
as one to form a collective narrative
similar to the theme of the show these
separate stories when brought together
form a stronger plot that echoes the
strengths of the characters when they're
brought together this is seen
brilliantly in the heist episode in
which the group used decoys to
infiltrate a den in order to steal
weapons so that they can better defend
themselves the show perfectly balances
all roles to show how the group are able
to move together as a cohesive unit
eventually the US government begin
bombing black areas which are deemed as
locales that the zombies have overtaken
this includes the majority of the West
Coast which is being written off and
plays heavily into Murphy's journey in Z
nation in the end the group discovered
through the military soldiers that
Spears is actually Julian James a conman
and murderer but as he's been escorted
out Rose saves him after she realizes
that there is no law anymore
everyone is trying to survive in the
military will probably betray her - it's
clear that everyone has their own goals
and just in the same way that Rose
wishes to find her daughter the
whistling man just wants to find his dog
and it's neat that everyone still has
something that they are fighting for in
the final episode the group launched an
assault on the stadium and chaos
confuse they fight through thick and
thin and browsers eventually reunited
with their daughter though it doesn't
seem like others will be so lucky
this shows that no matter what sometimes
the ones in power who we trust to
protect us aren't able to do so and are
powerless when it all comes down to it
jamie king who plays rose when
interviewed on the show stated that it's
an allegory for the detention camps at
the mexico border which were criticized
for holding children in an interview
King stated because I knew that I had
that I was rose I just it wasn't that I
had to play her I knew that I was her
and and I truly mean this it was one of
the best grips I've ever read it's like
you could taste it and touch it and feel
it and know it and there was a cultural
competency about it meaning that as a
storyteller what I care about is that
there's windows and mirrors so that
every person can see themselves up on
screen and and have can't relate to know
that they're not alone in this world and
and I was I was fascinated because you
know there was no mention of zombies or
anything like that and it was like this
this epidemic and I never know what was
gonna happen know what was gonna happen
and it was right at the time and
children were being ripped away from
their parents at the border you know and
I have been working on Hillary's
campaign for a very long time and
obviously you know really struggling to
understand what else I could do besides
making so many calls to senators and all
this and like I was just I and I knew
like I was like this is it this is it
and it was originally written as a love
letter John hi sorta is a love letter to
his wife like the strength of what a
woman can endure and what she would do
for her child anything
and when he saw what was going on the
country he was like that's it and
ultimately became the story of if we
continue on this path and it's just not
this country but anywhere what happens
when the the fabric of who we are as a
people is starting to be torn apart and
and you're a refugee and you're
completely ill-equipped to handle it and
so the government shutdown there's no
internet there's nothing and so when you
jump into this story you're jumping into
it with us and I kept asking him
questions I was like how long has this
been going on
we don't know I'm like well I need to
know I'm the actor like well you know
like we don't know and I I'm he
everything just had to be you know it's
definitely an interesting take on
society and it's what sets the show
apart from others this is a message
about coming together as one and how we
will always be stronger when we have
each other
this is a unique thriller and I highly
recommend that everyone checks it out
this weekend so what were your thoughts
on black summer did you enjoy it and
what did you take from the show comment
below and let me know and if you missed
yesterday's breakdown of Hellboy then
don't worry because they'll be linked at
the end this is the channel for people
who are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to Definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
you
[Music]